daniel jones last night played a
respectable game against the new england
patriots wasn't enough to win the
football game 15 of 31 not a great
completion percentage 161 yards one
touchdown three picks two carries for
eight yards he's got five touchdown
passes and six interceptions so far this
year as a starter he was asked after the
game were you overwhelmed out there by
the new england defense here's what he
had to say
i don't i don't think so i mean i think
you know i didn't i didn't play well by
any means i don't i mean i don't
mean to confuse that but i don't uh i
don't think it was overwhelming i think
it was just uh
bad plays bad decisions
yeah i i don't i don't like to critique
what guys wear to press conferences but
these guys are all highly compensated
he's got the tony romo shirt on the neck
neck on the shirt way too big for the
neck did you notice that he's got a lot
of room there he could go another inch
or or two with the smaller neck size on
this shirt if you're going to button it
up and wear the tie you got to make sure
it's a little a little more snug than
that against the neck big cat that
that's my clothing etiquette lesson for
today
mike he's dressing out of eli manning's
closet i think we can all see that like
he literally is before every game we see
this he's dressing up eliza manning's
closet i i understand what he's saying i
think he was overwhelmed and i think the
the interceptions and the fumbles
that daniel jones is showing is
something that has to make you a little
concerned because it's something that
happened at duke and now he comes the
nfl and the same problems pop up he has
eight turnovers in four starts he has
nine turnovers total
that's not good and figure it and it's
okay for a rookie because when you're a
rookie you're trying to figure
everything out and sometimes things move
a little too fast on you
the question though is does this
continue and does this become what
daniel jones is and is he the
injury-prone guy
but but let's find something positive in
what he did last night he went into
foxborough on a windy nasty night
without saquon barkley without saquon
barkley's backup wayne gallman without
evan ingram starting tight end without
sterling shepard top receiver and still
played a respectable game now the entire
team should feel good about keeping the
game respectable into the fourth quarter
but i think daniel jones did a lot
better than we've seen other
quarterbacks do in a situation where
they don't have the help they don't have
their their fellow starting offensive
players at key positions and they just
they just completely crater in the face
of a great defense yeah no he uh listen
i think daniel jones is gonna be a good
quarterback i'm i'm buying the daniel
jones stock right now
but wouldn't wouldn't you alternatively
say mike with three turnovers and the
defense playing the way they did in
terms of the giants you know getting the
strip sack touchdown helping out the
offense getting a a uh uh interception
while the patriots are going in for a
score the defense did a lot there to
help you stay in that game
you need to you need to repay that by
not putting them in bad spots with three
pretty bad interceptions a couple of
them look like what is he even looking
at so
okay i'll give him an okay because the
obviously the test was a lot harder than
than the normal test so we're grading
this all on a curve but i'm not going to
sit here and say he wowed me last night
or he did anything that was really
spectacular that kept them in the game
because in in reality he kind of hurt
them when their defense played better
than everyone expected
yeah i i'll agree with that i think that
they should be happy with where they are
right now with him i don't think any
giants fan has delusions of a playoff
berth this year this is about building
something for next year when it's daniel
jones and whoever they have as a backup
and eli manning is long gone and
speaking of that did you see the shots
of eli manning on the bench last night
he just looked miserable with the big
coat and the hat sitting next to daniel
jones and they weren't even interacting
he's just sitting there with the tablet
just i don't know what he's looking at i
don't know if he's checking his stock
portfolio or what but he just seemed
completely detached and disinterested
and and uh not what we were sold uh was
going to be the eli manning role he's
going to be the guy who's going to be
basically you know the coach on the
field and help daniel jones and i just
didn't sense a whole lot of interaction
between the two of them and and look it
may be that they were interacting like
crazy when the cameras didn't show the
two of them but every time they popped
him up he just was sitting there in his
own little in his own little world but
that's exactly what we were sold eli
manning was asked after he was bench and
he said he was disappointed and he
wanted his job back and he wanted to be
a starter so i i think he's been
consistent i think that the eli manning
is going to coach up danny
the mentor oh no no that was out there
that's you it's not that's the media
narrative
no yeah no it's not i thought they
should have just cut eli manning i mean
look and when we see the images we saw
last night what good why keep him around
why force him to stay because he's
because daniel jones is dressing out of
his closet
he's giving daniel jones clothes game
day clothes that's why you keep him
around
yeah
and they're paying them 11.5 million
dollars for that privilege
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports